tonight it'll be his 15th start on the
year a little bit of a mixed bag
walks are low
strikeouts are okay
slightly below average for a major
league starting pitcher and we'll give
you a little bit more one of two players
since 1900 to start a pitcher of the day
after hitting two home runs
of course in that club
babe ruth ohtani swings at this one and
lifts a high fly ball into left center
it's hit pretty well but it's playable
and a little bit of a collision out
there but
red gardner makes the catch on that one
angels have a base runner here's phil
gosling the angels clean up man
right it's well struck toward the wall
tracking and
goslin has just hit a home run a two-run
shot with two outs and the angels take
the early lead it's two nothing
decent is loose he spread his wings
going gets a right hand pitcher today
joe madding going with the right all
right even though he's got the great
power
versus lefty going the other way flicks
at the right center field
third home run for
gosling the goose
loose shohei ohtani it's just a day for
him too
those numbers are really good across the
board maybe the walks a bit if you're
looking for one thing about ohtani is
maybe overall his command at times and
center stage while he you knew that he'd
be fired up to come to new york three
straight walks to start off this bottom
of the first inning not what you were
hoping for certainly with the angels
with a two-nothing lead and shohei's
command is off giancarlo's at 265.
line drive a basic to left field
scores they'll hold great at third it's
an rbi single for stanton and so it's
now a 2-1 game bases loaded and no one
out the pitch to taurus hit on the
ground base at left field in the
shortstop hole
voigt scores and they'll hold the next
runner one base at a time base hit and
an rbi for taurus and the game is now
tied at two well here is anduhar this is
a big batter why because with one out
you can score on an out broken bat slow
roller two win two
he'll take the other first and one
scores yankees lead three to two on the
rbi ground out now frazier hit by a
pitch the bases are reloaded with two
out pitched a gardener inside ball four
gardner walks and forces in a run and
the yankees now lead four to two and
that is going to do it for shohei ohtani
so brilliant the first two games as they
hit her
but what a letdown and his pitching
performance here he will leave the ball
game now and aaron slagers takes over
and the pitch is grounded fair over
first down the right field line scoring
as torres scoring is fraser running
third as gardner and he will score
faces
and the yankees are pouring it on that
leads seven to two
closed captioning not
easily as available
they'll stop warded third
it's a couple of bases and one more run
back seven and three
vermont unable to support his team when
they support him yeah
another battery that has had a lot of
success against the yankees in this
ballpark coming through again like an
off-speed pitch change up hooked it down
the line
hooked it down in a corner a double
drive it run now 12 doubles on the
season 19 rbi great swing even on that
follow through at second base
and here comes the ground crew and there
go the angels so with the 2-1 count on
voight
they call for the tarp and that's going
to make things even more difficult
for bundy
if this game does resume after a long
delay does he come back out pitch the
delay was a little
quicker than we thought and with two
outfield pitch to gary sanchez grounded
on the third base side diving stop by
rendon gets up and throws to first and
does a good job there to retire gary
sanchez if that ball gets by rendon
that's two more runs that was a good
play and the inning is over so they
leave a pair on you can see the umpires
are trying to get this half inning in
because uh otherwise you wouldn't be
playing in this mess right now
walsh it's a high fly ball down off the
end of the bat but still traveling up
over and out of here jared walsh right
by the 385 sign it drops into the yankee
bullpen and that is a home run for walsh
his 19th of the season angels get a
little closer it's now 7-4 new york not
unusual to see him hit a breaking ball
out and with two out here comes the
catcher kurt suzuki hit on the ground to
third
and the throw to second for the fourth
to end the end
the yankees lead seven it's an official
game they did cover the field we have
our second rain delay the second rain
delay uh comes in at 91 minutes 91
minute rain delay bounces this one back
to the mound could be two second for one
relay to first it is a double play and
that is how the inning will end jonathan
[Applause]
he's been special
he had one or two subpar performances
but for the most part he's been money
out of the pen two away
and that will bring up gosselin sky
three fastball so lewisica has a one two
three
first out here in the bottom of the
seventh
and tyler wade will be the next batter
tapper back to him he goes to second for
one relay to first and it's in time
second straight inning the yankees hit
into a double play
and that is the third time tonight now
since play resumed the angels have had
seven straight batters retired he hits a
dribble in front of the plate sanchez
fields fires and it is in time for the
out and there are two way actually the
throw was high
voigt had to give a little leap and then
his foot came back on the bag just in
time to brett gardner were laid it off
yanks have a 7-4 lead swing on a high
fly to right that ball is high it is far
there is gone a home run for gardner
yankees lead eight to four as he has now
issued three walks here so nail bite in
time
here in the ninth inning for the yankees
and he swings and lifts a high drive
down into right center field it's way
out of here
the angels come all the way back
grand salami time for walshy wow just
like that halo magic iran heapho and has
the chance to be a hero
here and it's down for a base hit one
angel another comes on
to 8. now can't believe what i'm seeing
here tonight the angels this is an
incredible comeback so the batter now
for the angels is taylor ward and he
swings at that one and that is going to
drop in and that's a fair ball down the
left side the ball stops rolling the
angels are going to get another run on
that one what a comeback
fifo